chers amis chers ennemis re nous
recevons maintenant claude nougaro pour
fable de la fontaine aux bouffes du nord
du 3 au 11 mai bonsoir bonsoir toujours
très en forme c'est incroyable temps ne
peut rien contre vous en vous ne suivez
pas de quotidiennement et gêné période
également où la fatigue s'installe
inévitablement dans un corps cas quand
même qui compte 72 72
je le dis mais d'après ce qu'avec coq
est très bon mais c'est vrai nom mais
claude c'est vrai écoute vous devrez 55
en croatie comme le phénix que j'aime
j'aime la cendre j'aime le feu mais
j'aime les oiseaux mais ça conserve à la
poésie la bonne chanson peuple le sait
il pensait mourir raconte 3d était le
rêve de tout de tout jésus qui se
respecte ne pas en parler de jésus mme
jenny métaphysique de la peau dit
évidemment se voir un beau et crever
vite quoi
et puis finalement les ans tu arrives
dans le corpus dans l'habitat et puis tu
te dis finalement c'est pas tellement
c'est pas tellement désolant de vivre
encore un peu quoi tu t'attaches es tu
t'attaches même aux racines du mal
alors faire demain leur table de me
fontaine
donc c'est un spectacle alors qu'on n'a
pas encore vu parce qu'il commence le 3
mai il a commencé le 6 avril oui et ou à
tautavel en tournée
donc que c'est la catalogne française où
nous avons découvert le l'homme de
tautavel 450000 là c'est beaucoup plus
vieux vous effectivement oui alors alors
donc on a quand même on verra quand même
quelques images
on a un petit peu tourné mais c'est vrai
qu alors là vous alors c'est vrai qu'une
commission souvent alors parfois c il a
fait des spectacles avec un grand
orchestre ma voix avec avec juste
maurice vander au piano et là au plus
personne vous êtes tout seul
y a même plus de musique voilà y'a un
banc ya un ben oui alors en demande dans
la plupart de mes tournées de chanteur
j'aimais bien dire un poème comme une
récitation parce que il ya une histoire
de dents et parce que si je suis venu à
la chanson c'est par l'écriture et non
je dirais si je n'avais été comme
interprète j'aurais passé de la variété
j'aurais faire notre métier je ne sais
lequel mais je n'aurais pas été
l'interprète d'un parolier
par contre je me suis dit dans les
années 50 il y avait tout un tas
d'écrivains qui s'intéressait de très
près à la chanson sartre audiberti que
non tout le monde faisait ses coupés sur
des nappes et en même temps à paresser
les brassens et la suite quoi jusqu'à
gainsbourg disons et là je me suis j'ai
vu que l'amour que j'avais en moi de
l'écriture et de ma langue française
ajouter à ma passion pour les rythmes et
pour le lyrisme que je tiens de mon père
qui était baryton d'opéra rose alors à
l'opéra de paris
paris l'union oui c'était une une des
vedettes une des stars comme on dit
aujourd'hui du cas du capitole et des
grandes scènes françaises mais il était
premier britons à l'opéra de paris il
avait 27 ans dans le rôle rigoletto
scarpia
je connais athanaël parker thaïs et la
mère de pierre louis et ma mère lit et
ils se sont rencontrés au conservatoire
de toulouse
oui ils se sont aimés dans ce
conservatoire plutôt mon père et mon
avantage maman qui la petite [ __ ]
repart avec son père électricien qui a
tout d'un coup une mine d'or pour
électrifier saigon et donc ils partent
tous les trois et mon père reste seul
loin de celle qu'il aimait donc il fait
des effets des économies
il va marseille prend le bateau ici la
traversée un mois et demi à peu près à
l'époque moi bien tassée et pour aller
demander là sous les paniers les
ombrelles les plus parce que maman
depuis qu'elle était là bas ce n'était
plus à pitre macaronis elle roulait
calèche lé donner des leçons de piano à
toute la gentry sai gonesse de l'époque
et mon père est arrivé las comme un
vagabond pour demander sa main qu'il est
arrivé à obtenir
il manque aussi là bas on y est assez
bon passer les gants et hélas et est
sorti à tout mais ça m'évite du boulot
c'est moi la chance qu'on a avec tout ce
qu'ils racontent ce qu'ils racontaient
la déclaration j'imagine même pas vécu
vous l'avez vécu jeudi qu'il y ait eu
l'idée de supprimer la musique est de
dire les textes comme ça
est ce qu'il ne faisait pas aussi venue
de l'hommage que vous avez fait aux
victimes de la tragédie de l'usiné azf
toujours oui en déclamant toulouse oui
serré sans sa série sans nom mais encore
une fois je viens la chanson parce qu'il
me semble quitte à faire rigoler qui
veut que je suis fondamentalement un
poète
c'est à dire un type qui hobby à quelque
chose c'est quelque chose c'est la
langue dont je connais les aspects dans
ma langue à moi je suis incapable
on me dirais tu vas faire une carrière
internationale qui chante en italien
l'asnav ur c'est écrit dans le camp
français mais il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disent justement la chanson c'est assez
différent la poésie c'est d'y accéder
par ailleurs été rares ce que vous
appelez la poésie c'est à dire un mot
qui fait chier souvent injuste de livres
tout le monde parce que ce sont plutôt
ça s'est tellement intellectualiser
cérébralisé desséché que j'ai finalement
retrouvé la vraie celle de la poésie
sous les plumes de certains auteurs dits
de chansons je pense maintenant à jean
roger caussimon
car coécrite et c'est pas c'est pas joli
on était chasseur apollinaire parce que
la langue chante déjà quoi donc il ya
quand même une tradition poétique dans
la chanson française par exemple souchon
la dernière chanson que chante voulzy
une fille dafri evry le set bijoux bien
sûr oui mais vous êtes aussi influencé
par des auteurs qui ne sont pas que des
poètes comme audiberti et divertissant
il est surtout connu pour le théâtre
jeudi de cet impôt est mineur il avait
dit mineur de fond comme mineur
certainement charmilles winners on voit
lui un peu purgatoire audiberti oui les
romans en lice sont gilles publiant pas
à la à la sensibilité française qui est
plus près de ces panneaux voltairien
qualine langue claire tu vois valdes
audiberti c'était mon petit multi nous
allier plonge avec blanc et cheveux
c'est provençal c'est pas le génie val
de loire et ses falaises
vous avez été proche vous êtes ne vous
avez des copains écrivain je dire
ap parle de vous dans son genre
christian laborde les amis avec vous et
l'abbé louis
la dernière fois qu'on sait vous étiez
en train de lire le journal de paul
morand apporter à boire à claude barret
barman servait claudie à 17,17 la gorge
72 ans fumer des pétards
c'est fort bon ben alors le temps qu'on
serve à boire à claude nougaro on va
regarder un extrait du spectacle magnéto
jeu somme voici mon ami andré posément
avec précision je vis des monts 5
biblique mon oreiller ces restes tu
m'entends bien vendre et qu'on me prenne
sérieux et humanité toute entière
s'arracher son orbite de malédiction
guerroyant tu es fine fp a dégagé finie
la souffrance la sottise la chambre à la
lumière et à angré se massent
intensivement attentes
il me fit un sourire ému montré dans la
cuisine et devant un café m'explique un
que moi sensible mois enclin au
mysticisme sauvage mois devaient
considérer cette apparition
voilà donc toutes nos gars aux fables de
la fontaine du 3 au 11 mai au bout d'une
heure voilà d'islam cedus la main c'est
ça non c'est pas du slam parce que c'est
très écrit tandis que le slam et ça
c'est un peu gros quand même la halle un
procès dans le jeu de l'acteur est ce
qui m'a plus justement en revenant vers
mes sources d'écriture littéraire
ces deux d'être plus que jamais l'acteur
qui est en moi
j'ai besoin quoi sorte de c'est comme si
c'était parce qu'il s'agit pas
simplement de dire des récitations l'une
après l'autre
c'est relié par un fil rouge où il ya
une scénographie il ya ce banc que je me
suis fait faire par un designer argentin
femme plutôt rhinos haut c'est un banc
modulable parce qu'à travers le banc
c'est en même temps le banc j'ai eu
besoin sur cette scène désertes d'un
compagnon et j'ai pensé à un banc public
mais qui se module qui devient
évidemment le banc de l'école parce que
je repasse un examen le band et le banc
de sable le ban de la société
mais c'est quand même assez paradoxal
vous avez raison de défendre le travail
d'écrivain vous faites mais en même
temps dans une chanson comme toulouse
par exemple le texte est magnifique mais
les harmonies et les arrangements sont
bouleversants et ce qu'il faudrait quand
même pas saas cloud r go bridet pas
question de renier j'ai envie de faire
ça c'est pour me payer une saison n'ont
pas n'en faire qu'un degré arthur met
une petite saison dans un paradis où il
est très important pour moi
moi qui me suis toujours presque qui met
toujours en avant ce mot maudit qui
s'appelle la poésie où j'ai prétendu
être un vrai poète il n'y a pas de
petits a pas de grand évidemment les
grands poètes sont en même temps de
grands écrivains victor hugo n'est ce
pas c'est un grand écrivain et en même
temps c'est un grand poète baudelaire
n'est qu'un poète vers l'aisne n'est
comme poète
ce n'est pas un écrivain
mais c'est vraiment beau c'est vrai
claude vous avez été le premier
peut-être arrivé en france à mettre des
mots sur du jazz jazz et la java enfin
toutes ces chansons là une petite fille
en pleurs etc
c'est à dire que c'est vrai que vous
avez été celui qui a fait ça enfin moi
je me souviens à l'époque c'était
révolutionnaire votre travail parce que
jusqu'ici j'avais personnes étaient
arrivées à mettre des mots sur des
rythmes modernes parce que j'ai été
imprégné je suis au carrefour d'une
famille donc dite classique bel canto
pianiste schumann liszt verdi wagner et
tout d'un coup sûr la tsf de mon
quartier j'ai dans le tf il ya la voix
de louis amstrong qui sort et se c'était
en 1942 bessie smith glenn miller en
44-45 et l'a immédiatement devant mon
buffet la radio a été sur le bûcher dans
la cuisine je me suis mis à danser
devant le buffet et j'ai su qu'il y
avait un pacte quelque part avec cette
musique
ce génie noir de la sensualité de et en
même temps d'une sorte de serveur et ma
sensibilité à moi et la chanson m'offrez
précisément ce mariage entre mon amour
des de la prosodie et mon amour
lamy mais l'écurie mais c'était pas
facile parce que c'est vrai que c'est
pas une langue qui est fait alors
tranché été façonné par sa jeter
l'épongé de ça tombe bien ça tombe sur
moi
ouf bien ok et puis ensuite quand je
suis arrivé à paris
j'ai d'abord j'ai travaillé mes dents au
19e siècle aux la paire gille c'était du
bruant où on arrivait pour et en même
temps j'ai beaucoup appris de la beauté
de la chanson française de cette
époque-là de de tous ces chants
conviviaux comme ça qu'ils se chantait
en choeur avec des textes impeccable de
netteté de tu vois des choses admirables
je les verrai selon la page elle vous
oui on a passé ya pas longtemps une nuit
avec l'au-delà en mémoire de lycée
jean-monnet ma belle série voilà c'est
ça cetoula père gilles que j'ai
rencontré dans les années 50 marcel aymé
on caussimont jean paul c'était assez
bien fréquentée et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
il m'était impossible eux